PROFESSOR: This is a wonderful
differential equation,
because it carries a
lot of information.
If you put this
psi, it's certainly
going to be a solution.
But more than that,
it's going to tell you
the relation
between k and omega.
So if you try your--
we seem to have gone
around in circles.
But you've obtained
something very nice.
First, we claim that that's
a solution of that equation
and has the deep
information about it.
So if you try again, psi equal
e to the ikx minus i omega t,
what do we get?
On the left hand side, we
get ih minus i omega psi.
And on the right
hand side, we get
minus h squared over 2m and two
derivatives with respect to x.
And that gives you an
ik times and other ik.
So ik squared times psi.
And the psis cancel from the
two sides of the equation.
And what do we get
here? h bar omega.
It's equal to h squared
k squared over 2m, which
is e equal p squared over 2m.
So it does the
whole job for you.
That differential
equation is quite smart.
It admits these as solutions.
Then, this will have
definite momentum.
It will have definite energy.
But even more, when you
try to see if you solve it,
you find the proper
relation between the energy
and the momentum that tells
you you have a particle.
So this is an infinitely
superior version
of that claim that that is
a plane wave that exists.
Because for example, another
thing that you have here
is that this equation is linear.
Psi appears linearly, so
you can form solutions
by superposition.
So the general solution,
now, is not just this.
This is a free particle
Schrodinger equation.
And you might say, well, the
most general solution must
be that, those plane waves.
But linearity means that you
can compose those plane waves
and add them.
And if you can add plane
waves by Fourier theorem,
you can create pretty much
all the things you want.
And if you have
this equation, you
know how to evolve
free particles.
Now, you can construct a
wave packet of a particle
and evolve it with the
Schrodinger equation
and see how the wave packet
moves and does its thing.
All that is now
possible, which was not
possible by just saying,
oh, here is another wave.
You've worked back
to get an equation.
And this is something
that happens in physics
all the time.
And we'll emphasize it
again in a few minutes.
You use little
pieces of evidence
that lead you-- perhaps not
in a perfectly logical way,
but in a reasonable
way-- to an equation.
And that equation
is a lot smarter
than you and all the
information that you put in.
That equation has
all kinds of physics.
Maxwell's equations were found
after doing a few experiments.
Maxwell's equation
has everything in it,
all kinds of phenomena that
took years and years to find.
So it's the same
with this thing.
And the general solution
of this equation
would be a psi of x
and t, which would be
a superposition of those waves.
So you would put an e to
the ikx minus i omega t.
I will put omega of k
because that's what it is.
Omega is a function of k.
And that's what represents our
free particles-- omega of kt.
And this is a solution.
But so will be any superposition
of those solutions.
And the solutions are
parametrized by k.
You can choose different
momenta and add them.
So I can put a wave
with one momentum
plus another wave
with another momentum,
and that's perfectly OK.
But more generally,
we can integrate.
And therefore, we'll write
dk maybe from minus infinity
to infinity.
And we'll put a phi of k, which
can be anything that's not part
of the differential equation.
Now, this is the
general solution.
You might probably say,
wow, how do we know that?
Well, I suggest you try it.
If you come here,
the ddt will come in.
We'll ignore the k.
Ignore this.
And just gives you
the omega factor here.
That ddx squared-- we'll
ignore, again, all these things,
and give you that.
From the relation omega minus
k equals 0, you'll get the 0.
And therefore, this
whole thing solves
the Schrodinger equation--
solves the Schrodinger
equation.
So this is very general.
And for this, applies
what we said yesterday,
talking about the
velocity of the waves.
And this wave, we
proved yesterday,
that moves with
a group velocity,
v group, which was equal
to d omega dk at some k0,
if this is localized at k0.
Otherwise, you can't
speak of the group
velocity this thing will not
have a definite group velocity.
And the omega dk--
And you have this relation
between omega and k,
such a to way that this is
the evp, as we said yesterday.
And this is ddp of
b squared over 2m,
which is p over m,
which is what we call
the velocity of the particle.
So it moves with the proper
velocity, the group velocity.
That's actually a
very general solution.
We'll exploit it to calculate
all kinds of things.
A few remarks that come
from this equation.
Remarks.
1, psi cannot be a real.
And you can see that
because if psi was real,
the right hand
side would be real.
This derivative would be
real because the relative
of a real function
is a real function.
Here you have an
imaginary number.
So structurally, it is
forbidden to have full wave
functions that are real.
I call these full wave
functions because we'll
talk sometime later about time
independent wave functions.
But the full wave
function cannot be real.
Another remark is that
this is not the wave
equation of the usual type--
not a usual wave equation.
And what a usual wave
equation is something
like d second phi dx
squared minus 1 over v
squared d second phi
dt squared equals zero.
That's a usual wave equation.
And the problem with
that wave equation
is that it has real solutions.
Solutions, phi that go
like functions of x minus
is vt, plus minus x over vt.
And we cannot have
those real solutions.
So we managed to get a wave, but
not from a usual wave equation.
This, waves also all move
with some same velocity,
velocity, v, of the wave.
These waves don't do that.
They have a group velocity.
It's a little bit
different situation.
And what has happened
is that we still
kept the second derivative,
with respect to x.
But in time, we replaced
it by first derivative.
And we put an i.
And somehow, it did
the right job for us.